what up guys welcome to the justin
welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel today i'm going to be
reacting to jubilee um introverted guy
speed dates 28 girls and gave my
analysis on the interaction
um don't forget to subscribe because i'm
moving to england next month and i'm
really trying to get 20 000 subscribers
before i move i think that would be cool
um
so yeah hit that subscribe button the
video
i don't know if i'm more afraid of
meeting 20 people or being in front of
cameras i don't know which one's worse
[Music]
it's almost as if
it's only about you just teenagers right
they don't have to worry about anything
else they have to worry about no bills
and then at the same time they have
things like parents involved there's
school going on still so it's like
interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if anyone is
[Music]
am i a bad person for being a little
surprised none of you
none of you left
so as for physical attributes i usually
you know prefer someone that is shorter
than me but uh i'm
five nine if i strap on some basketball
shoes maybe i'm 5 10.
oh my gosh why are they having a text
instead of talk to each other that's
like the epitome of this generation
[Applause]
in terms of like their build and whatnot
i don't have too much of a preference so
much so that they're okay with my build
i guess you could say
[Music]
be confident kate why would you open
with that
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been with about three people was in
high school and
um
very
unpredictable as many high school
relationships are
[Music]
[Music]
everybody has things to learn from their
first relationship the fact that matters
that people's first ones aren't always
the best one and i would just
rather not be that first one
[Music]
it's interesting because would it be
better to be like because they're young
it's not like an older woman that's
never been in a relationship isn't it
better if you're younger
because i'm like her body counts
probably lower
more often than not i find that like my
like social battery sort of like runs
out faster than most people but i still
like to
go out and like be with people be around
people spend time with people
sometimes i can be a little bit like
i get too comfortable with with not
exploring and not seeing new things and
sometimes it'd be nice to have somebody
that could you know drag me out to
things or like convince me to to try
something new
[Music]
like this is such an awkward
why don't they talk to each other
[Music]
[Applause]
i how he doesn't
ask about like values or
like i don't know the stuff
that he's qualifying these women for
is not what i'd like tell my brother to
do
[Music]
if you had a deal breaker in terms of
love languages what love language
how do they know about love languages
he's 19.
i think definitely like receiving gifts
and then anything around the
idea of like materialism right because i
feel like it says a lot about a person
and and what exactly they value
getting gifts and receiving gifts and
giving gifts is like
what they're striving for in life i
think this is a lot
[Music]
a love language i like to give to
partners you know words of affirmation
words can hold a lot of weight sometimes
and people you know need the reassurance
and they need you know affirming
messages
[Music]
i don't know what mine is i think mine
is acts of service
and maybe words of affirmation
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
four we're down to four we're down to
four we're still good we're still good
uh hi
should we should we should we stand up
yeah yeah yeah how's this all for you
guys it's kind of scary
yeah you're telling me
actually liked yeah way they
communicated
he just thought she was hot stop capping
she was i thought that she was really
funny she did get um cut out on the last
one about love languages because i think
she was the one that like would fake and
stuff like that and i thought that was
really nice or the part that feels bad
is like i don't exactly like no no them
so it's just like it feels like i'm
already like
cutting that you know possibility off
without getting to fully know them yet
but do you think that the way that
someone talks through text can still
like reveal about their personality
there are a lot of you know um
shallow people i guess you could say
right that will
immediately judge you just from your
appearance um i guess through text you
really do get to
see people for who they are and again
you never know some people really do
feel to themselves when it comes to
texting or they have a different almost
personality sometimes when they're
texting in comparison to like being in
person
you guys um go to school or you work
yeah i go to school
yeah
where do you guys go i go to um
yeah i'm coming out that's where i'm
going to get my teaching degree and
everything oh nice
i would get really nervous talking to
people in general but it's like all
right i think i've seen enough
so interesting to see what like
younger people judge people on when
they're not necessarily dating to like
get married or anything
um because a lot of the stuff he was
saying i thought was kind of superficial
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys